think this is the beginning of a
beautiful friendship
good audiences need good films as good
films needs good audiences
it's there for everybody if we want to
work dream and try to get it if anything
can happen
thank people to love me thank you for
teaching us the power of resilience and
hope and for reminding us what true
kindness looks like
and the winner is the sound of music I'm
a waterfall West Side Story dances with
rules it will always be important to us
Godfather Gladiator A Beautiful Mind
Slumdog Millionaire the artist Argo the
shape of water remember that you are
part of our Legacy parasite no matter
thank you to the academy for letting our
family make history tonight